but welcome everyone we've got a short
15 minute sequence together today
so i want to get you up and away from
your desk if possible so
make your way over to somewhere that's
not your desk
come up into a standing position to
start and if you've got a map that's
amazing but if you don't
just imagine that you've got one and you
need that kind of amount of space
so when you make your way into your
standing position
just slide your shoulders all the way
down your back let your palms face
forward and then close your eyes down
when you're ready
can you quite literally just stop here
take a pause
before we get started and just notice
where you are
begin to draw your attention inwards
just away from the world around you away
from whatever's happened this morning
and just start to find yourself very
much in your body
grounding down into your feet take a
full breath in
and a full breath out
from here reach your arms all the way
out and up take hold of your left wrist
with your right hand
and then from here lean over towards the
right
soften your knees and here can you take
a big breath into the left side of your
body so imagine your left lung is
breathing here
and then bring yourself back through the
center take hold of your right wrist and
lean over to the left
soften your knees take a full breath in
from here bring yourself back to center
release the hands now behind your back
and you can either interlace your
fingers or take hold of opposite
elbows behind your back roll your
shoulder blades down your back
soften your knees lift your heart up
take a big breath in
from here bend your knees and start to
slowly fold yourself
forward so from here this is going to
look very different on all of us so you
might have to bend your knees quite a
lot
but see if you can ground yourself down
into your feet soft knees
and then let your head hang just as best
you can
from here you might actually move your
head a little bit side to side just
release any tension through your neck
and if you've still got your hands
interlaced behind your back can you
gently squeeze your shoulder blades
together
now take a big breath in right in
between your shoulder blades
and release your hands down to the floor
from here we take what's called a
halfway lip so you slide your hands off
your shins
if you've been to the gym and done a
deadlift it's kind of like that so
you move your hips back and the sternum
moves forward
see if you can find a really long flat
back here take a big breath in
from here slide your hands down the back
of your legs as you breathe out and just
fold all the way down
from here bring your fingertips to the
floor bend your left knee and step your
right foot all the way back
quite a long step staying on the
fingertips send your right heel back
your left knee
forward just starting to loosen up
through the hips a little bit can you
take an easy breath
from here lower your right knee down
point the back foot
and reach your arms up so this is called
a low lunge
and see if here if you need to you can
have your hands resting on your side
otherwise the arms can be up and
overhead see if you can invite
stretch into your right quad so you
might lengthen your tailbone down
lift up through your spine and look
forward
take a breath bring your fingertips down
to the floor tuck your back
toes lift your back knee step the right
foot forward now and again
fold so your feet are about hip distance
in their wings so two fists would fit
between the arches
then from here take your halfway lift
again so hands slide up the shins flat
back
inhale hands down the back of your legs
fold forward
exhale bring your fingertips down this
time
left foot steps all the way back left
knee down
actually lift your back knee back up we
took an extra moment here so send your
back heel back
right knee forward and see just how long
you can get here so big stretch the left
hip
find your breath gently lower the left
knee down now
then point your back foot as you press
down into your feet reach your arms all
the way up
give yourself two breaths here and see
if you can just keep inviting length
left quad left hip press into both of
your feet
and bring your fingertips down and from
here tuck your back toes lift the back
knee
and from here i'm going to give you two
options so you can either come into a
plank
or lower your knees and do a modified
whatever suits you from here settle your
eyes forward take a breath in
as you exhale bend your elbows and
slowly lower yourself down to your belly
so i'm hoping that you like this stretch
so you'll take your right arm
into a 90 degree bend take your right
elbow in line with your right shoulder
right hands flat
turn your head now to the left rest on
your right cheek
press into your left hand and roll the
left side of your body
on top of the right so if anyone's got
lower back sensitivity
just bend your knees and towards your
chest here
take a breath into your right pec your
right shoulder
i know we've all been sitting behind the
computer so just feel yourself reversing
that you're literally opening up through
your front
then from here extend your legs straight
come back onto your belly and we'll swap
sides so your left arm now goes out into
a 90 degree bend
turn your head to the right slowly roll
yourself onto your left hip
your right kid stats on top of it and
then maybe bend your knees
towards your chest right shoulder down
your back
and then here take an easy breath
one more
relax your jaw
and then from here bring yourself back
onto your belly
we'll come into child's pose from here
knees a little bit wider
than your hips big toes are together and
as best you can let your hips get heavy
towards your heels
if you can't bring your head down to the
floor forward down
you can stack your fists underneath your
foot
and i'm aware that it might not look
like this for everyone so just be nice
and gentle
soften through the front of your hips
and see here if you can breathe into
your lower back
so especially if you're feeling like
you're a bit depleted at the moment
or you're sort of teetering on burnout
anything where you breathe into your
lower back is really nourishing
the kidneys so take one more deep breath
down into lower back
and then from here release your hands
come on up onto all fours
from here we'll do a couple of rounds of
cat cow lengthen out your spine
inhale so here you keep your hips
stacked on top of your knees
shoulders on the wrists tail goes up
crown of your head goes
up and forward and then reverse that
round through your back tuck your
tailbone tuck your chin
spread your shoulder blades apart and
we'll do that
a few more times with breath so lengthen
out your spine inhale
round through your back and breathe out
two more lengthen and round as you
breathe out
one more
exhale from here slowly find neutral
spine
and from here make your way down onto
your butt
so from here you're going to bring your
legs out in front of you you can you can
face any direction that you like
and then from here reach your arms all
the way up you can bend your knees if
you need to
fold forward see if you can keep your
spine long
and then when you're folding you're
folding all the way you might walk your
sit bones back again
it might look like this for some of us
see if you can tuck your chin wherever
you are
you can always bend your knees and then
let your head go heavy
three breaths
where every time you breathe out it's
like you're literally releasing tension
you really sort of
stress from your body from your tissues
from your joints
it's letting go of the day that's been
and then from here use your breathing
just to slowly roll yourself
up from here reach your arms forward and
you're going to roll all the way down
onto your back
hallelujah and as you bring yourself
down to your back let your palms face up
and just close your eyes down here for a
moment
feel the floor
feel your breath
now from here bring both of your feet
onto the floor hip distance apart
bring your right ankle on top of your
left one
from here interlace the hands behind the
left side draw the left knee towards
your right knee away from you
this is optional so you might just leave
the left foot on the ground here and
take a full breath
in big breath out
releasing tension through the right
glute
hip softening your face
and then slowly you'll swap sides so let
go with both of your
both feet on the floor left ankle on
right thigh
from here interlace your fingers behind
your right leg draw the right knee in
towards you
shoulder blades down your back and see
if you can take
two relaxing breaths just give yourself
some space
when you finish your next breath out
bring both of your feet onto the floor
from here take your arms out into a big
t-shirt or that double cactus again
and let your knees just drop casually
over to the left
your head can go to the right
so any kind of twist is very nourishing
for your nervous system
nourishing the spinal column releasing
any tension
through your back your belly
in your own time swap it over your knees
will now go to the right your head can
go to the left
soft natural breaths
from here bring yourself slowly back to
the center from here hug your knees in
towards your chest
give yourself a big squeeze
and releasing to shavasana here which is
where you just lay yourself completely
flat that's probably what you've been
waiting for
slide your shoulders down your back
palms facing up
your feet will naturally turn out and
then take a full breath
in just feel like your whole body
sigh at your mouth
and allow yourself here just to dive
quite deeply into rest
just letting your breath be natural
letting your mind go wherever it lies
i'll let you know when it's time to come
back
slowly starting to bring your awareness
you relax your body even just 10 more
here
begin to deepen your breath
and from here roll yourself over to the
right for energy or the left
for a little more calm a fetal position
here so you can bend your knees just
rest on your bottom arm
and then from here bring yourself slowly
up into a comfortable seat
if there's such a thing you can
straighten your legs if you need
kneeling is welcome and then roll your
shoulders down your back sit up nice and
tall
hands on your thighs and then close your
eyes down
bring a little smirk or a smile to your
face even if it's from the inside out
and
notice how you feel
notice if you found a little more room
inside for breath
and for quiet in your mind
take a slow breath in
and an easy breath out
foreign and to each other
namaste
enjoy the rest of whatever today holds i
hope that was a nice
little pause for you and you feel like
you've got some space
thank you very much amy i don't know
about everyone else watching
but we here in the studio definitely got
a good stretch in
if you go on larsa's twitter you can see
some some nice shots of
the team here doing our stretches um so
that's really easy
yeah thank you very much for joining us
today emmy
thank you so much see you later